>> AND JEFF PAUL LIVE ON THE
SCENE IN CARSON CITY.
JEFF, THANKS A LOT.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE TONIGHT
ABOUT WHAT PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN
WANTS TO DO TO SLOW THE SPREAD
OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE ARE FINDING OUT THERE IS ONE
RELATED ADMINISTRATION POSITION
THAT IS PROVING ESPECIALLY HARD
TO FILL.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE.
>> THE PRESIDENT-ELECT BEGAN
RECEIVING CLASSIFIED INTEL
BRIEFINGS THIS WEEK BUT STILL
SAYS THE MOST PRESSING ISSUE IS
THE PANDEMIC.
>> THE FIRST DAY I’M
INAUGURATED, I’M GOING TO ASK
THE PUBLIC FOR 100 DAYS TO MASK.
JUST 100 DAYS.
TO MASK.
NOT FOREVER, 100 DAYS.
>> DESPITE THE FOCUS ON THE
VIRUS, BIDEN STILL HASN’T
REVEALED WHO HE WANTS TO LEAD
ONE CRITICAL DEPARTMENT: HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
NOW, RHODE ISLAND
GOVERNOR GINA RAIMONDO SAYS...
>> I AM NOT GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN’S NOMINEE
FOR HHS SECRETARY.
MY FOCUS IS RIGHT HERE IN
RHODE ISLAND.
>> THE NEWEST SHARE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION
IS UPSET ABOUT BIDEN INSIDERS
LEAKING ABOUT HER.
NEW MEXICO’S GOVERNOR TURNED
DOWN A NOMINATION AS
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR,
COMPLAINED TO INCOMING CHIEF OF
STAFF RON KLAIN TODAY ABOUT THAT
GETTING OUT.
ACCORDING TO A "NEW YORK TIMES,"
THERE IS MORE JOB SECURITY WITH
DR. FAUCI, WHO BEGAN BRIEFING
BIDEN TRANSITION OFFICIALS ABOUT
COVID TODAY.
>> I HAVE BEEN IN THE JOB FOR 36
YEARS.
IN THE SAME JOB WITH SIX
ADMINISTRATIONS, I FULLY, FULLY
EXPECT TO BE IN THIS POSITION.
>> CLIMATE POLICY AND ECONOMIC
POLICY WILL BE INTERTWINED,
ACCORDING TO BIDEN’S PICK FOR
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC COUNCIL, BRIAN DEESE.
>> I WILL POST EVERY DAY ON THE
BOLD NEW ACTION HIM A NEW TAKE
ON THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT-ELECT TO OUT
HIS OWN CABINET, EVENT PLANS TO
FOLLOW THE LEAD OF THREE
PREDECESSORS: OBAMA, BUSH,
CLINTON, WHO PLANNED TO BUILD
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE COVID
VACCINE.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO GET VACCINATED
BEFORE INAUGURATION DAY, AND
WILL YOU DO IT IN PUBLIC THE WAY
PRESIDENT OBAMA, BUSH, AND
CLINTON HAVE.
>> I WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
>> THE HAIRLINE FRACTURES IN THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT’S FOOT APPEAR TO
BE HEALING.
HIS DOCTOR TOLD US HE WOULD
LIKELY BE IN A WALKING BOOT FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS, AND WHEN WE SAW
HIM ON TUESDAY, HE WAS IN A BIG
WALKING BOOT, BUT WHEN WE SAW
HIM TODAY, HE WAS IN A SLIP ON